[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo después de que twitter
aceptara la oferta de compra de hilo
mosco mucho se ha hablado de lo que será
el futuro de una de las redes sociales
más influyentes del mundo en manos del
magnate el multimillonario ha recibido
aplausos pero también críticas por su
plan para según dice garantizar la
libertad de expresión en la plataforma
mientras unos argumentan que ya no habrá
censura otros temen un aumento en la
proliferación de contenidos dañinos pero
podrá el magnate hacer todos los cambios
que ha anunciado hasta ahora revisamos
la opinión de expertos empezamos
en diciembre de 2017 y lo moscú bromeó
al preguntar cuánto costaba twitter en
respuesta a la publicación de un
periodista que le sugirió que comprará
la plataforma para entonces no se pensó
que esto fuera una posibilidad y hoy el
multimillonario está a punto de
convertirse en el dueño de la red social
la compañía aceptó la oferta de compra
de masco por un valor de 44 mil millones
de dólares el que es considerado como el
hombre más rico del planeta dijo que su
interés en en adquirir la plataforma no
obedece a razones económicas y ha
insistido en que quiere crear un
escenario exclusivo para la libertad de
expresión y la mosca se opone a la
moderación que twitter ha ejercido sobre
publicaciones que promueven el odio la
violencia y la desinformación
la discusión se ha centrado en el rumbo
que podría tomar la compañía en manos de
iu la mask este ya ha manifestado
algunos de los planes que tiene para
twitter entre ellos según dijo mejorarla
a través de la implementación de nuevas
opciones como el botón editar combatir
los bots y el spam en la plataforma
autenticar a todos los usuarios reales
hacer público el algoritmo de contenido
es decir que por ejemplo permitirá a los
usuarios conocer los criterios por los
cuales la red social le mostró cierta
publicación en lugar de otra también
quiere eliminar el negocio de la
publicidad de la cual depende casi el
90% de los ingresos de twitter y pasar a
un modelo de suscripción pero lo que ha
abierto todo un debate a nivel mundial
es el hecho de querer flexibilizar las
medidas que regulan lo que puede decirse
o no en línea aunque sectores
conservadores lo aplaudieron y esperan
un espacio con menos controles sectores
liberales y activistas de derechos
humanos temen un aumento de discursos
dañinos
sin embargo y según expertos varias de
estas medidas se contradicen entre sí
así lo explicó a france 24 leandro ferry
él es global partnership manager en
ranking digital rights y también es
abogado especialista en política
tecnológica y regulación sobre el
derecho a la privacidad protección de
datos y ciberseguridad por un lado lo
que menciona sobre el brindar los
algoritmos de manera open source
y terminar con o eliminar todos los bots
de spam en principio serían como dos
cosas totalmente contradictorias
ya que por alguna de alguna manera si
estás brindando el algoritmo que
utilizadas por ejemplo para arrancar
contenido en el timeline o para tomar
ciertas decisiones sobre cómo se muestra
el contenido de alguna manera
las personas que desarrollan justamente
los bots de spam van a aprovechar todas
esas explicaciones para utilizarlas en
su ventaja y lo otros sobre autenticar
todos los humanos creo que realmente hay
muchísimas preocupaciones no sólo desde
el lado de la privacidad porque
implicaría que twitter tenga que
conseguir por ejemplo no sé desde una
idea gubernamental como un pasaporte una
cédula de identidad para poder como
asegurarse entre comillas que una
persona sea
como una persona física realmente con
una identidad como legal si quieremos
ponerle ese título
pero eso obviamente trae otro montón de
problemas que no es solamente desde el
punto de vista de la privacidad y
recolectar más datos sino también desde
el lado de la libertad de expresión por
cómo se perjudica las cuentas anónimas o
seudónimos que existen en twitter hoy en
día no además de quienes piensan que
estas propuestas pueden llegar a ser
contradictorias también hay quienes
creen que pueden llegar a ser difíciles
de concretarse y también quienes
argumentan porque twitter podría mejorar
en manos de más que echemos un vistazo
en un artículo de la revista
estadounidense the atlantic
el periodista derek thompson califica a
twitter como un mal negocio y
desconcertante mente torpe en innovación
parte de esto según dice obedece a que
está básicamente dirigido por un grupo
de personas que nunca usan twitter
refiriéndose a la junta directiva y
compara la plataforma con un restaurante
dirigido por chefs que nunca prueban la
comida por ello cree que más quién es un
usuario activo podría saber cómo
solucionar esos problemas sin embargo en
una columna del 'washington post' la
periodista mega mccardle muestra
escepticismo sobre los cambios primero
según dice porque esas grandes
diferencias podrían hacer de twitter o
menos viable que costaría mucho dinero y
porque ni siquiera hay lo más que quiere
un espacio verdaderamente no moderado
donde contenidos ilícitos y los tweets
de spam se pelean con la difamación y la
infracción de derechos de autor por
nuestra atención agrega que el magnate
enfrentaría una feroz resistencia de los
empleados y que despedirlos no sería una
opción práctica para una empresa de tal
magnitud
y es que además de estos desafíos y lo
más que debe recordar que twitter no
solo existe en eeuu y sus planes podrían
verse limitados por las leyes de otros
países que obligan a las empresas
tecnológicas a controlar el contenido
que circula en sus plataformas
recientemente la unión europea le
recordó a moscú que la comunidad tiene
reglas a mediados de abril los países
miembros y los legisladores del bloque
acordaron una nueva ley que obliga a las
plataformas a gestionar el contenido
dañino e ilegal como desinformación y
discursos de odio de no hacerlo podrían
enfrentar multas de hasta el 6% de su
facturación global
de esta manera despedimos esta edición
de revista digital recuerde que si
quiere repetir este u otro capítulo lo
puede hacer a través de nuestra página
web www france24 puntocom
[Música]